in his acceptance speech overnight
president-elect Donald Trump said
America needs to come together and quote
bind the wounds of division he also
promised to be the president for all
people on 60 minutes Sunday CBS News
contributor and Republican strategist
Frank Luntz gathered a focus group of
undecided voters it revealed how deep
those divisions are how do we get to the
point where every one of you with
different backgrounds different politics
different objectives all of you gave me
a negative reaction how did we get the
election how did we get here it's our
fault
you saw it here everybody's arguing I'm
afraid to even bring up a point
I'm not Pro Trump but I see why people
like it and you know if I say that I'm
gonna be you know ostracized my biggest
fear is that these candidates aren't a
mistake that the American people have
elected the future of America what we
aspire to be and what we are deep down
inside I think Trump has gotten so much
traction at this point because deep down
inside there are a lot of Americans that
feel the exact same way as that deep
down are cont our country is divided I'm
sorry we're not united we are at each
other's throats and I'm sorry maybe this
is what it is maybe this is the
candidates that we want Frank Luntz
joins us at the table there was so much
negativity with the group last night in
that group that you showed us on 60
minutes and last night Donald Trump has
promised to unite us when some so many
people believe he's the one that helped
divide this country how was he able to
prove or how was he able to prove to
people that I'm the one who can turn
things around how is he able to do that
well first last night's speech was the
best speech I've seen Donald Trump give
it truly was magnanimous he was reaching
out he said the kinds of commitments
that I was hoping he would say and he
appeared to be serious and if you doubt
it right and even his not well I doubt
everything about politics right now
let's start with the exit polls because
I'm a pollster yeah virtually every
state was wrong that they predicted
either the wrong winner or they were off
by four or five in Ohio is almost 10% it
was off why because Donald Trump
don't even want to participate in polls
they don't want to tell pollsters what
they're doing not because they're afraid
but because they're uncooperative
they're so hostile to the system that
they feel like that is giving in well
Donald Trump's campaign paid millions of
dollars to an overseas firm it is called
Cambridge analytic a five million
dollars in September alone
they used data points from gym
memberships from transactions on loyalty
cards charity donations all to target
their voters and the data people that
worked for Cambridge analytic assay they
knew over ten days ago that they might
win this election so are the pollsters
wrong and there's something there's
another new way to gather data out there
that the political class hasn't picked
up on yet you have to be able to read
people when they don't necessarily tell
you who they're going to vote for that
there are other things as part of the
decision-making process
Osama team did that in 2008 2012 they
said we can tell about what kind of car
you buy we can target you watch a
micro-targeting but but the issue now is
when you have when you are so upset with
the way things are going when you think
Washington has betrayed you and Wall
Street has betrayed you then you
absolutely you're not going to cooperate
and you're gonna find some other way to
express your point of view now I went to
a couple of Trump rallies on Monday and
what I saw were people who not only
couldn't wait to vote but they were
going to drag 1015 people with them
where was that the level of intensity in
Pennsylvania which he won and in North
Carolina which he won Hillary Clinton we
forget that Hillary Clinton was actually
not a good candidate in a traditional
election being first lady's Secretary of
State and senator would absolutely
qualify you and would probably propel
you to the presidency but if you have an
American electorate that is so angry
with the system and so angry with the
elites as part of the system that's
actually negative - yeah we hear that
she was not a good candidate before last
night absolutely like I'm hearing that
more and more last night until then
everyone you know she was Hillary
Clinton the most qualified candidate the
best suited for the job the best
temperament now is not a good candidate
that is being qualified and being a
great bringing a good candidate I
so she had a 43 42 percent favorability
rating before 53 54 percent didn't like
her we forgot that we weren't talking
about the fact that she had the highest
negativity of any Democratic nominee and
now we are being reminded of it and one
more we did a survey last night 1200
voters and we asked them if it was
Bernie Sanders versus Donald Trump who
would win by 8 points they preferred
Bernie Sanders over Donald Trump and the
reason why character we want to say that
elections are about policy they aren't
they're actually about who do you trust
who do you have more faith in and who do
you think understand you but you think
this election was more about character
or change I think was more about change
and it's not just changed in terms of
policy it's in terms of trust and they
simply didn't trust her and the exit
polls which I don't want to cite ever
again but even the exit polls talked
about the lack of trust in Hillary but
they also said that change was the most
important driving factor right and
that's why I don't understand why they
were so wrong why they had Clinton
winning in state after state that Trump
actually won this is a very interesting
I think it's actually a very good day
for democracy and it's a very bad day
for pollsters do you can tie yourself up
polls of course not okay I did yesterday
but today on our communication
specialist okay got it got it Frank
always reinvent yourself yeah yeah and I
have to do it every week so I'd become
good at it Jake Communications got it
okay thank you so much thank you